you can call me a conspiracy theorist
but I think a guy like Justin Trudeau is
watching that happening in China right
now and despite the fact that he's
saying all the right things we know what
he did to his truckers and the
protesters when they wanted to open up
Canada and I think he's watching going
boy it's possible if they uprise against
me again that Apple will help me shut
down their phones that that would be
pretty sweet like they're running a
little test over there but Kyle real
quick can you can you elaborate on what
you sent us right before the show this
uh this interview with Tim Cook that
just broke because it's pretty uh
telling of everything that's going on
here right I was keeping an eye on Tim
Cook uh you know any news with him being
confronted by reporters and Hillary
Vaughn over at Fox Business essentially
confronted uh you know and was there
when uh Tim Cook was asked three
different questions do you support the
Chinese people's right to protest
do you have any reaction to the factory
workers that were beaten and detained
for protesting coveted lockdowns
do you regret it restricting airdrop
access that protesters used to evade
surveillance from the Chinese government
do you think it's problematic to do
business with the Communist Chinese
party when they suppress human rights
he didn't even respond when he said do
you support the Chinese people's right
to protest uh and then do you regret
restricting the airdrop uh access that
protesters use to evade surveillance
from Chinese government uh completely
silent
um I I think that really this shows that
he is feels like he is under duress to
kowtow to the CCP uh and he doesn't want
to criticize them and you know look uh
it is not it goes beyond corporations in
this country we're seeing politicians
high level and officials we saw the dod
spocks the other day was asked at a
press conference uh about this and he
said the protesters speak for themselves
he couldn't stand with them it was
really unbelievable
um you know so I think like we're seeing
the elites whether they're corporatists
uh or you know CEOs uh you know in our
defense department they're on the same
page they're basically on the same page
with Connie's Channel as we saw and not
not to get too far foot but we saw
recently with the geofence data uh on
January 6. the FBI using NSA databases
to track U.S citizens uh they're using
see the Chinese style surveillance in
the U.S right now I think we've seen
some recent articles that that show that
um so right and and literally millions
of people in the United States have tick
tock on their phone which we know is a
spy up
and Eric swalwell uh slept with the
Chinese spy everyone knows that too and
he's still in Congress Melissa do we
have any leverage over China to do
anything about this whether it's
influencing Apple to you know help the
protesters or at least not harm the
protesters or anything else maybe
related to Taiwan or anything or or are
we just like we're bit players in
China's game almost at some level
well one one of the drawbacks of
globalization that we don't talk about
is that when um you know when our
markets were interlinked it became
really hard for our country and and
companies in our free country to
actually stand up for value for its
values and we saw that with the NBA and
it was so on such Stark display and what
we have instead is that the instead of
exporting our model of you know
political freedom to China it was the
other way around they exported their
brand of censorship and their way of
life almost we saw that with lockdowns